dude um what is it what so what's up
with jimmy fallon he's like played among
us live with like corpse husband and all
this [ __ ] i was like dying laughing
at two things one i imagine like corpse
husband speaking
and then mom's being like is something
wrong with the sound bar
this guy's voice doesn't it just doesn't
sound right
did you leave your phone near the
speaker again it's making a weird sound
jimmy jimmy i think you did it i think
you're suss
it's like a robot's coming through the
tv what's happening
then our [ __ ] eight-year-old is or
eight-year-old grandson is jumping in
the front no that's corpse husband
that's corpse husband
sounds like marilyn manson
is that little naz x guy
little massax the satan wore shipper
jimmy jimmy i think you did it
i had a really dark joke and we might
have to cut this one but
uh i was also chuckling at the idea of
like
every old person with a stoma from
smoking cigarettes all through the 50s
is like oh my god he sounds like me
yeah oh my god
no their voices are higher aren't they
uh maybe i don't know i don't be rude
about stoma but like
you know i just picture like a war vet
being like
where did he serve yeah
can i get one that sounds like that
something wrong with the soundbar did
you [ __ ] with the cables again
we gotta call best buys there's
something wrong with the sound bar
jimmy jimmy
uh never played uh fortnite on tv before
this is crazy
and jimmy fallon with a [ __ ]
controller like a goddamn plebe
what he's playing with a controller he's
like all right guys first i did that the
first time i played among us all right
so stop
i didn't know you could use keyboard i
wasn't aware i used keyboard the second
time
keyboard and mouse bro come on come on
man i know come on man
you didn't get the keyboard hey guys hey
what's up you guys
uh jen can't wait we're just trying to
get gen z to watch jimmy fallon
[Laughter]
yeah so they can yeah that's the other
great part about that whole thing is
like what are you gonna do guys
the writers at the late night you're
gonna get kids watching jimmy fallon
so they can tune in a week later to see
memes from
four months ago [ __ ] out of here yeah
i i yeah i i that
whole like late night shows are funny
obviously jimmy fallon i think he's
funny
i think that um this the
format though is tired and it's yeah
it's now they're trying to shoehorn all
these
you know like like you said kind of
recycled memes like they're too far
behind on it
like among us is now like it's like in
terms of
watch time and in terms of like how
often you see it on youtube it's over
yeah that was a you know that was the
beginning of the pandemic jimmy but
nice yeah yeah it just feels like and
now people are trying to take the late
night format to youtube and it just
feels like this
is a format that worked really well 10
years ago uh 10 plus 30
20 30 years ago yeah yeah yeah exactly i
guess in the 90s and
i like conan now
i it's like when people are used to
watching podcasts and like unfiltered
discussion on stuff it's like the overly
scripted like doesn't really hit his
heart that's why like you know as much
as i love sketch writing
like it's really hard to get someone
into that because
yeah they get like gta role play level
entertainment
where it's like true i'm not gonna watch
you and your buddies pull out a camera
and like go into character for three
minutes there's this guy on twitch who's
in character for [ __ ]
16 hours a day this shit's crazy
exactly yeah there's a [ __ ] literal
stream of a stop sign
we're just watching people pull through
a stop sign you know how entertaining
that
that can be the other is one of the
reasons why lily sings show didn't work
because they like
same thing they like try to do that
format but like use gen z
terms and jokes and stuff like that and
just like they sniff that out a mile
away it's like this is
fake yeah yeah i mean that's the other
part
which is kind of interesting is i think
every new medium
like live streaming all that stuff like
scripted writing the point of it was
what if this would happen but now we've
seen that a lot of those things
either do occur or they can occur or
someone can make them happen
and so like
reality tv and like scripted not just
blends and now it's just like
content you know what i'm saying yeah
like you know like milk
like you know they take what video they
posted recently like you know
kyle gets some girl's number and there's
like a hundred dudes come running out of
a tent like so
funny that's such a great prank yeah
it's like it's you know it's wholesome
it's innocent whatever
um but like that's something i think
someone would have scripted
20 years ago or even 10. been like dude
imagine like
if a dude got a number and then all his
frat boys came running out of a house
and then now it's like 100 guys are
willing to do it for the gram
so yeah i don't know bro
weird times yep
more yep yep yep more black mirror talk
i like talking about content honestly
yeah
i mean do do you have like this like
where do you go from here feeling i have
this [ __ ] so often
yeah but i think we're making the right
moves i think we're like i said it's
gonna be an exciting month and i think
that
we're i'm excited personally and i think
we're making good decisions so
yeah yeah yeah no yeah definitely i
think everything we've got planned is
is for sure the way um
let's see let's see the the vaude do you
have it luke
he said he's got it ready to go also he
said can't wait for jimmy to get banned
from no pixel in a year
jimmy fallon he just gets you from
what's up guys we're playing gta
today fan out meta gaming you just broke
the rules you're gone
hey guys welcome to my twitch channel
this is my first twitch stream so
thank you for watching uh there's gonna
be uh
probably a lot of mistakes but uh it's
gonna be fun either way
thank you so much for watching and then
and tuning in and playing with us and
streaming with us so we're going to play
a few rounds of among us uh for those of
you who don't know because it's going to
be air on the tonight show it is a
game um well we're going to play we're
going to play a few rounds of among us
and we're going to do it
hold on pause it for a second one more
time wait this is actually on tv
or was this on his twitch i think it's
like
i think it's uh their twitch channel oh
and then they're putting clips
from it on the tonight show maybe yeah
i don't know yeah yeah that's what
caused it yeah yeah okay so this was
he actually started a twitch channel and
he
that wasn't that the most boomer way and
listen i don't i don't have any hate
towards jimmy i really don't
i really don't i know i feel bad because
he's a nice guy and it's like
he just comes from a different era of
entertainment and i just i just like i
feel for the guy
like he you know he likes doing this and
he's just being told like this is the
way
but listen man when you're on twitch
coming in and going yo welcome to my
twitch chat
ah [ __ ] yeah yeah that's exactly what i
was just thinking
what's up guys welcome to uh my twitch
channel this is the first time that uh
we're gonna be doing this
so it might be some bumps along the way
but bear with me uh
okay so today we're gonna be playing
among us poggers poggers
poggers pepe laughs pepe laughs pepe
laughs pepe left february
foggers yeah i mean i that's what i'm
saying i don't [ __ ] blame him it's
just probably his producers
who are like already you know two years
three years too late to twitch that are
like we should start a twitch channel
he's like all right just i'll do
whatever
yeah i'll do whatever to bump the
ratings you know
yeah so i feel for the guy you know
you gotta i mean that's how i feel on
tick tock i feel exactly like that on
tick tock
yeah yo what is up here is another
joke what is up tick tockers
here is a fun sketch i've been thinking
about bodybuilders be like
how about that backflip though
new tick tocks every thursday at 6 pm
who the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] that'd be so funny
oh my god late night guy doing tick tock
make sure you're hitting that
notifications bell on my tick tock
channel
new notifications new tick tocks every
thursday at six
that's going to be dropping a new tick
tock see my new character on tick tock
late night guy doing tick tocks
what is up tick tock i have a guy who
owns a monkey
clap it up for that he's gonna put it on
my shoulder
oh yikes
[Laughter]
everyone's like boo have you seen the
account where the guy actually has a
monkey living in his house yeah he cut
his monkey's hair